our Siri is a more perfect union
continues this morning and it aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we introduce you to Louisiana's
Teacher of the Year her name
Kimberly Eckert she teaches English at
brouilly High School near Baton Rouge
over the course of her decade-long
career she started a unique tradition
she writes personal letters to her
students to ease some of their anxieties
and to let them know how much they mean
to her
this year alone she wrote more than a
hundred and fifty letters imagine that
well we met some of Eckert's past and
present students who wanted to return
the favor they share just how much she
meant to them it's treating them with
dignity and it's treating them with
respect that you matter you might not
have seen it yet but I saw it I saw it
the second I locked eyes with you you
mattered before I ever met you this
experience it's my job to help you feel
just how very very much you matter she
saw me and that was something new to me
I just felt like there was just this
arrogance that I had and I feel that now
I'm just so much of a better person and
I can't begin to thank her enough for
that she was different because she
always came checking on me and she was
like other teachers they just seen a
howl and that's it I think there's like
if there's anything that that I've
learned words have a lot of power and
the way we use them and how we use them
and the timing and using them is
sometimes all the power that we need
it's all the power we need and I think
that with my particular students and in
their generation the frequency that they
see words they can kind of forget the
power of just a letter they can forget
the power of feedback written on a paper
I did get a letter mailed to me after
school was over and I think got it like
summer time but it was just a bunch of
pausing
the things to let you know that I'm not
going anywhere we can talk anytime I
wrote this letter to her she always
writes from other students I feel like
she decided to get one herself
okay dear mrs. Eckhart like many others
entering high school a big part of my
freshman year was trying to find my
place
he showed me a side to myself that I
didn't even know existed seeing you
always be you showed me that it's okay
to be different and explore new things
you taught me to be a more open-minded
and kind-hearted person who is willing
to put forth the effort to make a
difference in this world
you immediately saw potential in me I
love that you gave me responsibilities
you made me step up and grow up and live
up to my potential
you was labor as a teacher but in my
heart your and Romano for I learned how
to truly feel empathy for others before
students to be vulnerable and
uncomfortable or challenging initially
it was necessary to grow
I feel super lucky because I had the
opportunity to be taught by you to be
able to touch again the way you touched
me would make everything so worth it I
can truly say that you were one of the
teachers who made me better there are
certain teachers that live in your life
forever
and you are one of them much love
Gabrielle Myers sincerely love jasmine
for the fairly love miracle
sincerely Lauren Walker kind of sir
guards Alexander Joseph's fencing
Wow guys is right I would think as a
teacher it doesn't get any better than
that
well the difference that you made in
somebody's life that those simple words
in a letter that express empathy and
kindness and compassion and tell you you
know I think you're so great yeah we're
never grown is about three sizes
watching that yeah and just as simple
words of thank you thank you mrs.
Eckhart
thank you mrs. Eckhart and the other
teachers who are doing yes deserves it